why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so as we get into our discussion about
the New Mutants we're going to need to
take a step back here and we're going to
need to look at more than simply just
the story involving The Brood that led
into the creation of the New Mutants we
actually need to take a step back and do
a little bit of discussion about this
channel so far for those of you guys
that were with me from the beginning we
had talked about how over the course of
this channel we were going to be getting
into stories we were going to be getting
into things where this channel was going
to start moving in a Direction Where We
were going to have to reference back to
the old stuff now for you those of you
guys who are new you guys didn't know
about this you guys didn't know that
this is what we were going to be doing
and so New Mutants is going to be our
first step in that direction this is our
first step in a much bigger picture and
the reason why is because the New
Mutants is going to allow us to segue
into introducing all kinds of new
characters into Marvel Comics The Helen
Seline Deadpool this is going to give us
the uh the stories whereby these
characters are brought in and the reason
why is because this story was founded
and it was created by both Chris
Claremont and Lis Simonson and the
reason why was explained to us in Wizard
magazine issue number 24 in August of
1993 and what Louis Simonson had said
was that Jim shooter who at the time was
head of Marvel wanted to start bringing
in all these different ti-s wanted to
start I guess creating all these
different branch offs of the X-Men due
to the popularity of the X-Men under
Chris Claremont now initially Chris
Claremont and Luis Simonson didn't
really want to do this and so what jimm
Shooters said was that either they can
do it or he'll have somebody else do it
in their place and because Chris
Claremont was considered the rider the
one person that could best create a
story based on the X-Men and Louis
Simonson had found her Niche an xfactor
it made sense that they would be the two
that would collaborate to create a
branch off of the X-Men titled New
Mutants now in terms of the new mutants
actually coming into fruition or I guess
being created this was given to us in
Uncanny X-Men issues number 155 through
157 and issues number 161 to 167 and
what we saw over the course of the
stories was an introduction of an alien
race called The Brood Now The Brood are
an alien alien race that can effectively
plant a uh I guess embryo of sorts into
a host and the MBO will grow it'll be I
guess it'll develop and it'll take on
both the traits and the appearance of
its host but the host will die in the
process but what the embryo also does is
it takes on everything that makes the
host what it is so it takes on their
memories it for the most part becomes
the host and it allows that information
to be sent back to the hive mind to the
actual brood Empress the head of the
brood hierarchy which in turn can be
used to expand the brd's Empire as it
seeks to to uh conquer that particular
uh race that it's somehow managed to
duplicate now with Uncanny X-Men we had
s seen over the course of these stories
that the sister of Leandra deathbird was
looking to usurp the Throne of the shiar
Empire and so to do that she had I guess
Allied herself with the brood but
because the X-Men were considered very
close to the shiar through Xavier and
Leandra her goal was to uh somehow find
a way to eliminate the X-Men and this
worked well for The Brood because the
reason that the that this worked so well
was that the brood could replace the
X-men with brood replicants and so they
could then turn and I guess undergo the
process of Conquering the planet Earth
and so what we saw was that over the
course of this uh of this these this
series that the uh concept had come into
existence the idea had come uh come
along that the X-Men appeared to have
been converted into brood and the
original X-Men had been killed off now
this was from the perspective of Charles
Xavier now we know this wasn't the case
we know that Carol Danvers who at the
time was powerless was experimented on
by The Brood she became the character
binary and Chris claremont's attempt to
rewrite her character but because
Charles Xavier didn't know this he had
believed the X-Men had been killed off
and so initially his idea was to walk
away from the concept of uh having an
X-Men team walking away from his dream
of having some sort of group that can
fight on the side of mutants and attempt
to do what it can to find a democratic
and a peaceful way to coexist with
humans but as we'll see throughout the
introduction of New Mutants in graph in
Marvel graphic novel Issue Number Four
we'll see that Charles Xavier will begin
to change his tune and this tune will be
changed due to a series of circumstances
which force him to come into contact
with the New Mutants but also due to
some prodding some poking and prodding
at the hands of Mora
[Music]
mctaggert so unlike X Factor or
Excalibur or Generation X where we went
into an explanation on the uh comic that
first introduced us to these teams with
New Mutants we're actually going to be
skimming over this pretty fast and the
reason why is because we're going to be
covering a lot of things over the course
of the New Mutants uh in Marvel Comics
in a very short amount of time and so as
we're introduced to this story we first
pick up with Mora MCT tager and Mora
mctaggert is spending time on the side
of a hill more or less collecting her
thoughts and she encounters uh
apparently a wolf which has leaped over
her and this is a surprise to Mora MCT
tager because as she tells us wolves
haven't been seen in that part of the
country for Generations but as things
progress she realiz realizes that this
is not an ordinary wolf that the wolf
actually begins to change form and when
it does it changes into a girl named
Reen Clare also called Wolf's Bane and
what Mora mctaggert does is she protects
wolfbane from the people who are
pursuing her individuals who believe
that she's somehow a witch or in League
with Satan because they don't understand
the premise of what mutant powers are
now Mora MCT tager is able able to uh to
vouch for the young girl and able to uh
tell the individuals to back off which
they do and more m Hager takes wolf
Spain to the only person that she thinks
can truly help her which of course is
Charles Xavier from here we switch to
Robert deosta or Sunspot and of course
in Brazil he's in the middle of a soccer
game and as he's in this soccer game
he's being bullied by another one of the
players who physically assaults him
because the referees don't see it and no
one makes a call Robert deosta begins to
get angry about it and so he takes
things into his own hands and when he
does his mutant Powers begin to manifest
as he's taking a beating from the uh the
person who was bullying him and the
mutant Powers as they manifest caused
the person who was fighting him to be uh
I guess blown away and the the people
around him begin to Panic of course his
family with the exception of his mom
runs off and she seems to be the only
person that's willing to comfort him
from here we switch to Sam Guthrie or
Cannonball and of course he's the son of
a coal miner who had previously been
killed in a coal mining incident and
while Sam and another cooworker are
working within the mine there's a
cave-in and during the cave in of course
Sam's powers manifest as he's trying to
find some way out for the two of them
now what do powers do are allow him to
project or catapult himself out of the
uh out of the mine and into the nearby
woods now initially his coworker chocks
this up to a miracle and Sam agrees
although Sam has come to the realization
that he's developed abilities and is
still trying to figure out how to deal
with this from here we switch to
Danielle Moonstar to Mirage and Danielle
Moonstar appears to have already had her
powers manifested they seem to have
already uh made themselves known and of
course she's confronted by her
grandfather who tells her that because
of the abilities that she possesses that
her best uh I guess choice or her best
role here is to go to the Xavier
Institute of gifted youngsters and
initially Danielle Moonstar doesn't want
to do this she feels as though uh that
that Charles Xavier is an outsider that
he can't understand her people and Chris
Claremont keeping Trends with racial
issues and dealing with uh real world
events in Marvel Comics of course uh
takes homage to this when Daniel
Moonstar says that Charles Xavier is a
white man and that she'll never go with
a white man because he can't truly
understand her but of course her
grandfather says that she doesn't really
have a choice in the matter that she has
to that it's it's really his command
that uh is making this happen what we
also see with uh Danielle Moonstar is
that she has a premonition of sorts
where her grandfather is killed and when
she arrives to the scene she sees that
he is dead and of course for her she
knows that uh this wasn't some kind of
an accident she knows that somebody has
intentionally done this this that
somebody has killed her grandfather and
so for her this is simply just a matter
of a personal Vendetta that needs to be
solved at this point we switch back to
the Xavier Institute and we join Charles
Xavier wol Bain and mor mctaggert as
they're uh I guess investigating the
powers of a young woman who will go
under the name Mirage now this woman is
able to as she explains it take over the
minds of other people and possess them
and when she does she effectively
becomes that person she knows all their
experience she knows everything it is
that makes them who they are and so for
her this is an ability that allows her
to directly tap in to a person's very
essence now initially Charles Xavier
asks her to display her abilities and at
first she's a little hesitant she's not
really sure that she wants to but morea
MCT tager tells her to go ahead and do
it on her to use her powers on her and
so what Mirage does is she takes over
she takes she possesses the body of Mora
MCT tager and becomes Mora MCT tager and
as I guess operating under Mor mctaggert
she demonstrates her abilities tells
everybody that this is what happens when
she takes over the mind of a person that
she has absolute control of their body
and so Charles Xavier who's uh very
surprised by this who is Amazed by this
agrees to uh bring Mirage on as part of
this uh this young group of mutants but
from here this is when we see Charles
Xavier begin to second guess himself
this is when we see him more or less
debating whether or not this is
something that he really wants to get
into of course uh what what more mcag
hints at us here what she tells us here
I guess figures out along the way is
that mirage's powers had more or less
just developed on their own they had uh
come I guess they had come to her and
she had developed them by herself
without any assistance from anybody and
the reason why was because she comes
from Vietnam and during this time
Vietnam was very War torn and so she had
to learn to adapt she had to learn to
use these abilities to her advantage in
order to keep her from I guess
acquiescing to the negative environment
that was vietn Nam at the time what we
also see is that Raina believes that
maybe these powers that she has are a
cursed from Satan but what Charles
Xavier says is that's not the case the
powers she has are natural it's simply
the next step in human evolution and
that it has nothing to do with Satan or
any kind of religion whatsoever it's
simply just the way that her body is
evolving from here we see that more
mcgard and Charles Xavier begin to get
into this debate of course Charles
Xavier is is communicating with morea
MCT tager telepathically and because
Charles Xavier's open this telepathic
Bridge more mcag is able to communicate
as well and what Charles says is that he
doesn't want to do this anymore that the
ex-men were like his family and that
with their death he's experienced the
death of his family and so he doesn't
want to undergo this process again but
more MCT tager says that this is the
nature of being an X-Man that the idea
they fight for is more important than
their individual lives and so X-Men will
come and go people will join the X-Men
and they will die for the cause because
that's the nature of being an X-Men man
Mor MCT tager says that this is the
whole reason why the team was founded
that Charles Xavier had created the
X-Men for the purpose of teaching
mutants how to use their abilities
teaching them how to function within
normal society but also having mutants
use their abilities in such a way to
where they would be superheroes and they
would be accepted and they would be uh
able to blend in and I guess Bridge a
gap between the perception of uh of
mutants by humanity and the realistic
nature of mutants by humanity and so
from here we see that the group gets a
gets a letter in the mail and the letter
they've received is from the uh
grandfather of uh of Daniel Moonstar the
grandfather of course is writing to
Charles Xavier saying that he would like
Daniel Moonstar to attend the Xavier
school for gifted youngsters for her to
learn how to control her powers and so
Charles Xavier and the group travel back
to uh to the Indian Reservation now from
here we pick up at at the actual
location in Colorado of this reservation
and when they arrive they realize that
uh that Black Eagle the grandfather of
Daniel Moonstar has been killed and so
the question that Mirage asks here is
what are they going to do how are they
going to be able to find Daniel Moonstar
if her grandfather the only person that
knew where she was is uh is now deceased
but before they can go too much further
they're immediately bombarded by what
appears to be a um I guess a Vietnamese
infiltration force or perhaps something
to uh give them the illusion that they
are back in Vietnam and again this is
simply Daniel Moonstar using her powers
and this is when it's explained to for
the most part I guess in any real detail
what it is that she's able to do Daniel
Moonstar is able to cast the Illusions
or cast Illusions in the mind of a
person but the Illusions are based on
empathy meaning that she's able to tap
into the emotions of a person and so she
can create Illusions based on their
worst fears or based on their happiest
moments it depends on what it is that
she wants to do but being that as we see
with her character she's being pursued
she's using her ability to cast
Illusions into anybody around her and to
to force them to flee of course the
forces that are currently chasing her
are the forces of Donald Pierce a member
of the hellfire club who is attempting
to eliminate all mutants and trying to
start with uh with the younger
generation of mutants and of course as
these forces are chasing after her her
uh her Mountain line comes to the rescue
but the mountain line Ridge Runner is
killed almost immediately and so as a
result Daniel Moonstar begins to get
angry but of course uh as she's about to
be attacked and presumably killed by the
forces of Donald Pierce we see Mirage
comes and comes to her Aid and what what
Mirage does here is she takes over the
uh I guess the the the mind and body of
this particular agent and when she does
the agent starts killing people it
starts killing the other forces of
Donald Pierce and so with Donald
Pierce's force is now more or less I
guess eliminated uh the group led by
Charles Xavier alongside Daniel Moonstar
are able to gather together again and
able to uh Retreat back to their current
location from here we transition to the
hotel room that uh that Daniel Moonstar
that Karma and that um uh Mora MCT tager
are staying in and it seems as though
these individuals that have appeared are
police officers and the police officers
are here to arrest uh all of these
individuals now initially Mora mcag asks
why does the police are here but she's
immediately assaulted for her
questioning and the group of is of
course taken by the police but what uh
what Karma does in the process is she
takes over the mind of one of the police
officers and so when the police officer
goes to put handcuffs on her he doesn't
actually secure them the handcuffs are
loose and of course this is done by by
Karma herself as soon as the group gets
down to the lobby the police officer
that Karma Is possessing assaults the
second police officer and the group
takes this time to make their escape
into a crowd outside of the hotel from
here the group is transitioned back to
the home of Robert D Costa and what
Robert deosta is doing is apparently
leaving now of course the group is
following him as they were instructed by
Mor mctaggert to do and the goal here as
far as we can tell is for them to
possibly try to recruit uh recruit
Sunspot and as they follow Sunspot they
end up in a warehouse in the uh I guess
the slum District of Rio De Janeiro now
apparently as far as as far as we're
able to tell Sunspot had come here and
said that he would agree to hand himself
over if they would release Juliana but
of course the forces refus to do both
and so what we see as things progress is
that while Sunspot tries to use his
powers that he doesn't quite have
control of them and so he is almost
immediately overpowered by the forces of
of Donald Pierce but before things begin
to get too chaotic Karma again uses her
powers to I'm sorry Mirage uses her
powers to create Illusions in the minds
of other people to uh Force One or I
guess a multitude of these henchmen to
see Wolverine and of course Wolverine
during The Uncanny X-Men events with
their encounter with the hellfire club
had already come into contact with a
multitude of these henchmen and so for
them their worst fear is to actually see
Wolverine
and so of course with the Illusions cast
alongside the actions of the remaining
members of the New Mutants they're able
to assist in trying to help Robert D
Costa Escape but over the course of the
conflict one of the henchmen tries to
shoot Robert D Costa and when he does
Juliana jumps in the way and the result
is that Juliana is killed now of course
Sunspot takes this very very hard but
what we see is that there's some common
ground that's found between Karma Mirage
and Sunspot when Karma and Mirage say
that they want to help Sunspot get back
at the person that's done this because
the person that has put them in the
situation is targeting all of them and
so in a way they can all gain their own
Revenge from here we transition to uh
Charles Xavier and to Wolf Spain and the
two of them are apparently traveling
through Kentucky looking for sun or
looking for a cannonball but when they
find him it's actually due to the fact
that he has rammed into their vehicle
and sent their vehicle toppling over of
course Charles Xavier tells wolfbane to
run and w Spain while she initially
takes off thinks that maybe she can turn
back around and she can try to help
Charles Xavier but when she looks back
she of course sees that uh that
Cannonball is dragging Charles Xavier's
body away now Cannonball is apparently
working for the forces of Donald Pierce
although at this moment we don't exactly
know why it seems like he is
legitimately on the payroll and so we
don't know if he's somehow being coerced
or if he's doing it of his own accord
but the group is able to load up Charles
Xavier and take Charles Xavier away in a
helicopter from here we follow wolfbane
as she is tracking down the helicopter
and this leads her to a compound that's
of course surrounded by fences and very
various forms of security she's able to
get herself past the fences and into the
compound itself and when she does she
looks inside and sees Donald Pierce
alongside the henchmen and what Donald
Pierce is doing is he's telling Charles
Xavier what he wants to do of course he
tells Xavier that his plan here is to of
course uh I guess remove Charles
Xavier's ability to uh use his mind to
combat any of them but the other purpose
of the devices attached to Charles
Xavier is to allow Donald Pierce to use
Charles Xavier's mind to locate a
multitude of other other mutants which
of course he can in turn eliminate and
this is the motivation of Donald Pierce
Donald Donald Pierce is part of the
hellfire club is attempting to eliminate
all mutants everywhere including those
who are part of the hellfire club and to
to I guess move himself up to the very
peak of the of the male position in the
hellfire club as the black king
and of course as uh as moonstars I'm
sorry as um as wolf Bane is looking at
this the other members of the um New
Mutants arrive but in addition to the
arrival of these other New Mutants comes
Cannonball and this is when it's
revealed to us that it appears
Cannonball really is working for the
forces of Donald Pierce of his own
accord and of course Cannonball is able
to uh knock down Wolf's Bane but as he
is getting ready to attack Wolf's Bane
again Karma uses her uh I'm sorry Mirage
uses her power to to make him believe
that he is back in a uh in a I guess a
cave- in that he's back in the cave or I
guess in the uh the tunnels in Cameron
Kentucky and is experiencing a cave- in
once more and so because of his uh fear
because this is overwhelming him he
takes off and what the New Mutants do is
they use this time to break into the
facility to attempt to rescue Charles
Xavier and for the most part they're
largely successful albeit they're still
learning how to use their powers over
the course of the conflict we of course
that um that karma is trying to use her
ability to tap into the mind of uh of
Cannonball but because she's so panied
because she's so overwhelmed she's not
able to concentrate and so instead she
simply grabs a machine gun and begins uh
shooting at the forces of Donald Pierce
from here we transition to the interior
of the uh of the compound as the New
Mutants are making their way in of
course wolfbane is the first one to
attack Donald Pierce but she's thrown
off almost immediately to the side of
Charles Xavier and appears to be
unconscious Mirage arrives and attempts
to cast Illusions in the mind of Donald
Pierce but Donald Pierce says that
because he's part cyborg that these
these effects don't work on him that
psychic attacks don't affect him or at
the very least the kind of a psychic
attack that she's attempting to use
doesn't work on him from here we again
transition back to the rest of the team
as they're going in turn to do what they
can to try to defeat Donald Pierce but
while this is going on Charles Xavier is
speaking with wol Spain and he tells her
to use the console behind him to to turn
off the uh the machine that is attached
to his head so that Charles Xavier can
use his powers and as we move forward as
we continue with this story We of course
see that Cannonball apparently begins to
come to a senses that perhaps he
realizes he's fighting on the wrong side
and when Donald Pierce realizes this
Donald Donald Pierce attempts to kill
Cannonball but before he can Charles
Xavier whose mind has apparently been
released from its control uh takes over
Donald Pierce and when he does while
it's a struggle he overcomes he's able
to effectively shut down the mind or at
the very least take over the mind of
Donald Pierce to keep him from killing
Cannonball from here the Story begins to
wrap up we of course see that the New
Mutants are able to save wolf Baine
they're able to uh overcome Donald
Pierce due to the fact that he's now
under the control of Charles Xavier and
the group is trying to decide what it is
they should do with Cannonball what it
is they should do with him but the
initial idea is to simply just leave him
to let him uh come to his own terms and
to do what he wants to do from here we
go back to the Xavier Mansion about two
two to three weeks maybe a month later
and Charles Xavier is reflecting on the
X-Men the original X-Men the new
generation of the X-Men and he's come to
this realization that he does need to
undertake the role of having X-Men the
X-Men need to exist there has to be
someone that can be out there and that
can somehow try to bridge the gap
between humanity and mutant kind and so
of course we see that the uh the New
Mutants are putting on their new
uniforms they're getting getting
themselves dressed and as they meet with
Charles Xavier we see the Cannonball
that Sam Guthrie arrives and Charles
Xavier tells them tells the New Mutants
not to panic that he invited Cannonball
here that Cannonball had been tricked by
Donald Pierce into believing that the
New Mutants were the bad guys but as the
story and as the events had progressed
Sam Guthrie had come into his own and
realizing that it was really Donald
Pierce who was the bad guy and so as the
story comes to a close we see the New
Mutants coming together and greeting uh
Sam Guthrie as their newest
[Music]
recruit so after Marvel graphic novel
Issue Number Four New Mutants of course
got their own solo series with New
Mutants issue number one and over the
course of these Comics we saw a lot of
things beginning to change we saw all
kinds of stuff going on with these
stories because again New Mutants was
running alongside the X-Men we saw new
people being brought in we saw Cipher we
saw magma we saw magic the younger
sister of Colossus warlock we saw a lot
of these characters coming into play but
in the background over the course of
this series we also saw things changing
with regards to individuals in 1986 we
of course saw the trial of Magneto
something we had touched on in the uh in
the X-Men explained video and with the
trial of Magneto as we had previously
discussed Magneto was turning over a new
leaf and so with Charles Xavier being
removed as the leader of the X-Men
Magneto took his place now this of
course coinci ided with New Mutants
issue number 35 and remained for about
40 issues or so but again what we saw
over the course of this series and over
the course in the background was that
Chris Claremont was also launching his
own Branch off series most notably the
series of Excalibur and so with uh issue
number 55 in 1987 Chris Claremont had
walked away and the series was turned
over to Luis Simonson but Louise
Simonson was also doing xfactor at the
same time and so this is one of the
reasons why we had seen characters like
RoR and skids who were part of xfactor
being folded into the new Mutant story
but over the course of the three years
which Lis Simonson was writing the
series alongside xfactor the series
began to slump it began to drop off
because the very gritty element of the
characters which Chris Claremont was so
well known for began to kind of go away
but by uh 1991 or so Rob leafield was uh
introduced as part of the uh as part of
the the New Mutants lineup now at the
time he wasn't necessarily a main
Creator I guess a main Creator in the
series he was more like a co-creator of
sorts but by issue number 97 Louise
Simonson had more or less been been I
guess pushed out the door she wasn't
really eliminated from the series so to
speak but she was certainly being handed
her hat and what Rob leafield had done
is he had taken these concepts of
characters that had previously existed
and began to fold them in and this is
when we saw the New Mutants starting to
move in the direction of uh a
combination with uh with cable being
introduced and then moving in the
direction of the actual xforce team we
of course saw with New Mutants issue
number 98 the introduction of Deadpool
but with issue number 100 in 1991 the uh
new Mutant series was brought to an end
and when it was the New Mutants
themselves were rolled over into the
actual group X Force which was led by
cable and this is something that would
go on for a number of years until about
2002 when the overall X4 series began to
come to a close now eventually Marvel
would bring the xforce series back they
would reboot it with uncanny xforce but
again this wasn't a series that was
wildly well-received and so overall
Marvel brought the whole thing to an end
but again this is the significance of
New Mutants in Marvel Comics New Mutants
allowed us to be introduced to a
multitude of different characters but we
saw with the New Mutants aging with them
getting older that the series grew the
series progressed new things were being
introduced and Marvel began to segue the
entire X-Men or I guess X Universe
concept into a new Direction in the
1990s by Crossing it all over into a
multitude of different series ultimately
culminating in the 1995 Age of
Apocalypse story line with that being
said we're going to go ahead and bring
this to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later
peace I can feel you go I need to feel
you glow
[Music]
oh